how do I find my true calling I got a
question from one of my newsletter
readers love you guys I knew who wrote
in to say thanks having for your
thoughts it's really starting to make
sense to me but how to identify where I
start how do I recognize what is my true
calling this is one of my favorite
questions to answer and it kind of
bothers me that I have to answer it so
much not from you guys but but we as a
society are failing we're failing our
young people today I don't understand
why this isn't being taught how can we
teach our children math and history and
science and we prepare them to get a job
but we never teach them how do you find
your passion how do you find your
purpose how is that not taught in our
schools a lot of you're saying we're
preparing an entire generation of kids
to have no idea what they want to do
with their lives
anyway blows my mind but I'm happy to
answer this question I answered a lot of
different ways from a lot of different
people I've could entire Zuka guide on
this zuga 101 is find your passion at
step by step of how to do it but I'm
going to summarize it quickly in this
video it's so important that you find
your purpose that you find your passion
because it makes life meaningful right
when you know why you're here when you
know what you're doing when you're doing
things everyday that bring you to a
point where you feel alive that's where
you want to be most people live their
life like this they're all over the
place and they're unhappy but when you
know what your passion is when you know
what your purpose is your life is a lot
easier right you know who you're
supposed to hang out with and who not to
you know what opportunities to take and
which ones not to every decision becomes
easier and you're living a life that is
purposeful that is happy you're adding
value you're helping people and you feel
good and I want that for everybody so
how do you find it you got to remember
that your purpose is going to be a
combination of something that makes you
happy with something that adds a lot of
value to other people's lives you are
happiest when you're serving other
people we are we are born and meant to
serve others right we feel happy
when we're helping somebody else out
with something and this can be through a
business or it can be through your job
or whatever it is but you will find your
greatest pleasure and happiness when
you're adding value to somebody's life
so the combination of what you love
doing something that you love doing so
much something you you wake up but you
know say 9:00 in the morning you start
to work at it's you look down you look
back up in a 6 at night you're like
where did where did everything go where
did the time go
because you're so in love with what
you're doing so think about all the
things that you love doing that you can
get lost in and then think about how you
combine that to help other people when
you can merge those two things together
that's when you find your purpose that's
when you find your path the things that
you love doing with the things that help
other people that combination is unique
to you and when you find it you'll feel
amazing your life will change everything
will change
and it's so I'm glad you're asking this
question because it's so important for
you to figure out for everybody to
figure out so start making a list write
down the ten things that make you
happiest the things you can get lost in
and then try to apply those to how you
can help other people with it you know
if you like helping entrepreneurs right
that's what I do I love helping
entrepreneurs how do I apply that right
so I can make videos I can do consulting
I can create content I can sell
advertising right so think about how you
can take what you love doing and turn
into something that helps people and can
also make you money in the process
because the more you help people the
more value you're giving the more money
you're going to make in the process to
believe those you're watching I'd love
to hear you have to think how did you
find your life's purpose how did you
find your passion leave it in the
comments below or if you haven't found
it yet tell me what you're struggling
with I'm gonna make a video response you
guys like this video please give it a
thumbs up below and click on my face to
subscribe to the channel and see more
videos like this thank you so much I'll
see you soon